es una palabra que al gobierno francés
le gusta usar leer claro y transparente
así que hoy seguridad transparencia
transparencia total total transparencia
el presidente francés emmanuel macrón
siempre ha prometido que sería lo más
abierto posible sobre la vacuna para
combatir al virus y creo que es
importante decir en este momento que hay
muchas cosas que aún no sabemos sobre
este virus y obviamente no sabemos todo
sobre la próxima vacuna el mayor desafío
que tendrá el gobierno francés será
convencer a los escépticos de las
vacunas en el país ya que encuestas
recientes mostraron que el 61 por ciento
de la población no quiere vacunarse
en primer lugar existe la creencia común
de que la vacuna se desarrolló demasiado
rápido la gente tiene miedo porque es
extranjera lo que podría cambiar la
opinión es si las dos primeras semanas
desde el lanzamiento de la vacuna van
bien y si muchas de las personas que se
vacunen pueden decir que es fantástico
volver a la vida normal pero si el
gobierno no logra convencer al público
francés su mejor apuesta es hacer que
los médicos puedan hacer el trabajo por
ellos las encuestas también muestran que
la gente en francia confía más en sus
médicos de familia que
políticos negación eso es la mejor
manera de tranquilizar a los pacientes
es darles archivos completos e incluso
revistas médicas para ti que existe una
relación única entre un médico y un
paciente y eso puede generar más
confianza que si usted fuera vacunado en
un centro o con muchas personas supo
cómo equipo fue el gobierno confía en
que su estrategia de implementación de
vacunas sea un éxito todo esto en un
intento por cerrar el capítulo sobre el
coronavirus en el país